a Houston Texans football star has
started a crowdfunding site to raise
money for disaster relief defensive end
JJ Watt has reached his $200,000 goal he
did it in less than two hours Watt told
us via Skype that he feels helpless
waiting out the storm in Dallas while
his hometown of Houston suffers to see
it going through such a disaster and to
not be there to not be able to help it's
very difficult to have to watch it from
afar to see it on TV and look at streets
that you know and you can barely
recognize them underneath all the water
so it's just very difficult the people
of Houston are very resilient people are
always willing to help each other and
that's why we started the fundraiser
that's why we've started this situation
so that we can get the help that these
people need there's gonna be families
that need to be put back together
there's gonna be communities that need
help rebuilding their homes their parks
everything and that's we're gonna try
and do is help those situations out and
what has now raised his goal from two
hundred thousand to five hundred
thousand dollars I think it's hard when
you don't have a personal connection to
Houston but it certainly must be very
difficult when as he pointed out you
know these streets you know this area
it's got to be very painful to watch
Kevin Hart is also calling on his
celebrity friends to step up when you
put out the call people do respond yes